maybe we should just get the elephant in
the room out of the way um before dj
joins us here
um i'm just sitting around
going about my business
last week was right around this time as
a matter of fact
seeing the johann howard throwing hands
or mush or whatever
everywhere i mean like it was non-stop
nonstop on a loop
and uh the combine uh bubble pops you
know the uh the league or
uh the scouting com
organization that runs the uh the
combine backs off and says yes everybody
can have their trainers and you can have
whatever food you want and
you know we'll deal with covet another
day i guess and um and so dj sends out a
tweet thankful that um that all the
prospects were going to be there there'd
be no boycott thank goodness i was
getting a little nervous it would just
be rich eisen and me talking current
events so rich i haven't watched much
college basketball this year how's your
michigan squad doing
i love that all right
let's pop them up right now you there
daniel jeremiah how dare you
yeah i feel like this is i feel like i'm
getting set up here i feel like this is
walking into a trap right now there's
not at all i mean this is a handshake
line i'm extending my hand if you want
to just throw hands then then we'll have
to figure that out
why do i feel like this is like a stone
cold steve austin you shake my hand and
then you hit it with a stunner
i have that that's just not my arsenal i
come i i come and uh i come in peace i
always do that
i don't know what why take a shot at me
like that daniel why would you do that
well you know i
you your football team had such a great
year and as we head towards the spring
as you know my my favorite part of the
spring is is not necessarily the combine
or the draft it's just giving you and
charles davis so much crap for the
failures of tennessee michigan now yes
michigan's good and i'm like i don't
know where i don't i'm like a a
rudderless ship right now i don't even
know where to go
so
uh you search for that uh that i guess
the port in the the sea of troll
and
that port you dock your boat in is the
michigan basketball team is basically
what you're saying well i mean
i was being honest i have not watched
much college basketball
neither neither do i because i had no
idea appalachian state was in fact
better than michigan in terms of record
and the opportunity to make the
tournament so i don't know that's why i
had to look that one up you did
i wish i'd looked it up before i
responded but i just got so pissed i
don't know
you usually don't inspire anger in me
like that daniel but no you know what
and the funny thing was my first my my
first uh reaction was i can't believe
juwan howard took a swing at him and my
second reaction was how long has juwon
howard been the head coach at michigan
yeah
well you know what back here on the rich
eisen show with daniel jeremiah we just
hashed out of him taking a a figurative
swing at me on twitter over my coach
taking swings on the basketball court
getting ready to go did you see did you
see my other tweet to you last night
rich by the way with the with the news
about mike yeah apparently some guy at
supercuts whatever uh has nothing cuts
hair and gets tips yep and uh his tip
was that uh you're you're the the first
choice for fox with troy aikman leaving
uh for the booth oh right
congratulations well he said the other
people he named were over sean payton
nate burleson and condoleezza rice i
didn't know that those are the three
other uh options for fox i had no idea
you know so yeah i mean i think i think
is what i was told according to the guy
from super cuts it came down to me and
condi and uh it was a close call but i
think i edged her out you know what uh
thank goodness
that would be in football and not
foreign policy let's put it that way
she definitely has the edge on that
i probably wouldn't both haven't heard
her talk football all right daniel i'm
i'm so excited to be ready to spend an
insane amount of time with you in that
booth at the 50-yard line at lucas oil
stadium um what is the main headline
going into the combine in your
estimation dj well i think this i think
this league rich as we saw in the super
bowl is about
quarterbacks and those who can get to
the quarterbacks and i think you know
maybe some of the headlines have been
well this isn't the sexiest quarterback
group um you know after what we saw last
year and what it looks like could be on
the horizon next year but if this is a
draft where you're looking to find guys
who get to that quarterback you are
going to love it it is loaded with edge
rushers you've got two from your school
yep um among about six seven or eight i
could see going the first round and and
getting ready for the combine and
talking to guys who've been training uh
these dudes they're gonna put on a show
for us rich so i can't wait
and yet uh your mock draft going into
the combine it's 2.0 for those who might
have missed the 1.0 that came out in in
uh i guess january um evan neal um the
protector of uh all alabama crimson tide
quarterbacks is is going to be the
choice of the jaguars they're going to
go to try and protect trevor that's what
their choices do you think when it's all
said and done yeah and again you know
that's that's how you know i do the mock
drafts kind of what i think they would
do not necessarily what what i would do
or how i have guys ranked um in my
updated top 50 evan neil is my fifth
player um i i like him i like the pass
rushers better i just think you know if
we if we fast forward a year from now
rich and the jags are coming off of uh
you know a five and twelve season
and you know the defense has played
great because you've added hutchinson
and you've paired him up with josh allen
but the quarterback doesn't take any
steps forward i i think they would they
would kind of view that as the
organization not necessarily where it
needs to be whereas i think if they're
the same five and twelve team and
they're maybe giving up some points but
um you see the trajectory start to take
off here for trevor lawrence i think you
feel much better about things so i just
feel like this whole offseason it
started with doug peterson um every
decision that jags make is going to be
to try and help out their young
quarterback and so you've got um the
giants
who have two picks
in the top
ten right
they've got five and they've got seven
and in your mock draft you have them
taking no offensive linemen
uh a pass rusher trayvon walker of
georgia and then drake london a wide
receiver you
you think that that's what they're gonna
do um when when it's so clear that that
line is so dreadful is that what you've
got on your list well here's the here's
the here's the challenge is first of all
i think they're going to try and trade
out okay um i think that's what they're
going to try and do if they can find a
partner because they have a lot of holes
to fill they need to uh
clear a bunch of salary cap space so i
don't know how much they're going to be
able to do in free agency but yes the
offensive line is a glaring need but
with with evan neil and equanu off the
board
i think you're probably extending and
reaching a little bit now i i don't
think you know carolina from everything
i've been told to fix right behind them
is
they are they are dead set on the
offensive line and i mean to me it was
like put to me from somebody who's tied
in there uh with those guys that just no
matter what just give them an offensive
line and even if you think it's a reach
um so that's that's what i did with them
but with the giants i think you know you
you look at the other areas of this
football team they need to address maybe
they can do it with some low price uh
free agents i just look at joe shane and
where he came from in buffalo no first
round picks on that offensive line but
what they did is they got serviceable
players and then they used their
resources including trading you know a
one for stefan diggs to put weapons
around josh allen so that's kind of the
theory of where i went with that of
trying to give daniel jones some more
weapons i really like cadarius tony but
i'm not going to make you know joe shane
and brian dave all pay for the sins of
the previous group that paid kenny
galladay all that money um so i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna sit and wait for him
to be a great player because i don't
think that day is gonna come your next
10 fascinating in the fact that these
are where the two quarterbacks in the
draft you have going in the first round
reside because you have only two guys
going
in your first 32 at the quarterback
position none in the top ten you've got
kenny pickett going to the saints 18th
overall and then the liberty quarterback
monique malik willis
to the steelers
20th overall walk me through your
choices here and also to leave matt
corral
out of the first round entirely
yeah you know matt corral unfortunately
not going to see him throw
or do much at the senior bowl he's
coming off that injury in the bowl game
he played in uh he's got a really live
arm rich he plays really really
aggressive uh and he does that with his
leg that you know he's not a big guy i
don't think he's gonna physically hold
up playing that aggressive with his legs
he's gonna have to dial that back um
it's kind of a tough offense to evaluate
out of as well um kind of some some
schemed winners in there with with lane
kick and rpos it's just a he's a tough
evaluation so
that's why i had him kind of sliding out
and then
you get to kenny pickett with the saints
you know it feels like to me this is
kind of a not a rebuild but uh you know
definitely kind of a new chapter here
with dennis allen taking over
uh they don't have their quarterback
answer there and i think when you look
at playing indoors playing and where
they're going to play in that division i
think it suits kenny pickett with his
you know with his skill set doesn't have
an overpowering arm but really good
accuracy and decision making so i like
to fit with him there and then malik
willis again you know the mock drafts i
do off of what i hear and what i think
could happen and uh the buzz down there
in mobile at the senior bowl was that
the the steelers seem to be smitten with
malik willis so they wanna you know a
lot of times it's like when you fire a
coach you hire the opposite
i think we can see a little bit of that
too when you change quarterbacks i mean
it doesn't get any more opposite than
going from joe flacco to lamar jackson
um so you stay inside the division you
go from big bend to malik willis you get
a lot more athletic and kevin colbert
does what ozzie newsom did
on the way out the door is leave the
next guy a quarterback to go forward
yeah i mean i i mentioned that to ed
bouchette last week and he kind of
poo-pooed that in a way you know the
long-time chronicler in in the steelers
in pittsburgh and um
you know but i also did hear tomlin say
that um that mobility at the quarterback
spot is something that he would love to
have right so yep that's those those two
things make sense right there a little
breadcrumb right there but uh and then
there's the issue of uh of the
quarterback market shaking out in the
new league year as well as maybe after
all that with deshaun watson and what
aaron rodgers wants to do and
russell wilson is the latest quarterback
to remove um or not have any mention in
his twitter bio or social media bio of
the team that currently has him
um so how do you see all of that playing
out uh obviously that would wreck a mock
draft that's why it's a mock draft for
everybody so just to go back to your
homes is not the real thing
um
right so so how do you see the
quarterback market going into the
combine whispers and ear to the ground
daniel yeah i would say a couple things
rich you bring up uh some great points
so that would that would be a great
opportunity for me to say
pay more attention to a top 50 list or
whoever you follow and whoever you trust
with their information a mock draft
prior to free agencies just a fun
exercise but i don't know how useful it
is but if you can kind of get a feel for
you know how you stack the players and
how you like the players how you rank
the players i think that's more valuable
and i would say you know how it impacts
what we have going forward over the next
few weeks as we head towards free agency
i don't get the idea that anybody's
super enamored or in love with this
quarterback class uh and what that uh
tells me is that we're going to see some
teams trying to get bold and trying to
be pretty aggressive in the veteran
market so that should be a lot of fun
well who's going to be available in the
veteran market do you think do you think
aaron rodgers
i think it's going to be trying to give
teams an offer they can't refuse so
maybe some guys that you don't think are
you know potentially available maybe
they get blown away and they do become
available um i would imagine there's
going to be several teams that try and
take a swing um you know with aaron
rodgers with russell wilson particularly
um and then we're all i mean i feel like
we've been saying the same thing forever
we're all just playing the waiting game
on watson
and then um anybody that we're not
talking about what do you think
you think i don't know you know there
was some talk about you know cousins and
and what could happen there i think once
they hired kevin o'connell i kind of put
that to bed because
i don't think you're allowed to be a
membership of the shanahan coaching tree
unless you pledge your allegiance to
kurt cutler
i
don't see that happening
you pledge allegiance to kirk cousins
is that where you stand up there hand
over your heart yeah that's how it works
that's really funny hold on i'm gonna
write that out today i'm gonna write
that out one quarterback under center
yeah with operations and interceptions
for all
[Music]
this three three-step drop ivy pledge
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show
how do you think the uh statement from
kyler murray's agent eric burkhart
landed on the desk of steve keim as he's
making his way to speak uh in front of
the
combine uh gathered media tuesday what
do you think about that statement daniel
i i mean i don't want to put words in
steve's mouth i've known steve for a
very long time i would imagine he
probably no he probably just had a
little bit of maybe a chuckle on an eye
roll
and one about his day um i i don't think
that i don't know what the point of it
was you know like are you trying to
apply public pressure
you know like you're trying to get the
the fan base to rally behind a guy who
scrubbed all of the fan bases teams
information from their social media
accounts like i
i don't get it i i don't i don't see
that's applying any leverage
um you know i i kept reading i was like
okay where does it say he's going to
hold out like i was kind of missing that
piece of information um so i i didn't
really get the uh
the motive behind that if whatever it
was i don't think it was accomplished
so
let's dive into it like what
because i said at the top of the show
daniel that if you have spoke to any
cardinal fan
they're not worried if kyler murray is
the right guy at all yeah
they're worried about why does this team
fall apart after thanksgiving that's
what they're worried about and if that
is the problem of the mix of the team or
the organizational
um you know uh roster building or the
coach like that is the question or
you know is it something that that will
not be able to be fixed with murray like
deep down
um that might be the concern about
murray long term not about like signing
him now because he's not the right guy
like there's no wence
goff problem here right so
i guess
that's my first way to dive deep in is
like what is the problem what has been
the problem in your estimation
in arizona well i think i think you know
they've had
some issues with some injuries i think
he's just physically worn down at the
end of the year too you know and the
first you know year before it was more
injury related this year is a little
more performance related um
but yeah i mean that's that was the
other thing it was kind of missing from
that you know from that statement or
what have you is like hey we've
accomplished some great things but you
know i know that i need to get better
and i'm working on that yeah so that i
can finish uh stronger than i have the
last couple years but maybe like a
little bit of accountability if he took
there uh would it would have made that
land a little bit better um
but no i mean i think they got to
continue to add depth i mean we've seen
that especially we're in 17 game season
now rich and when we have had with the
coven uh stuff i think hopefully that's
behind us for the most part but uh the
deepest rosters are the ones that uh
that advance and move on so they've got
to continue to add talent and depth
around kyler but he's not he's not
you know he's not someone who doesn't
deserve a little bit of criticism as
well for his play coming down the
stretch so i think it's just i think he
probably thought he was going to get
kind of the rubber stamp josh allen
kind of name your number let's just get
it done and pay you um and i don't i
don't think he's getting that
so then why not that's the let's say
let's flip this on its head then um in
the fact that you know everything that
eric burkhart did say
um in it about how the franchise has
turned around and how well he has played
is is fact and that what i said is
clearly he is the quarterback of the
future for the cardinals then why not
give him what he wants right now what's
the point of that
well i i think that they i think he is
going to be their quarterback i don't
think there's any other option but i
think they're maybe not putting him in
the josh allen category yet you know if
you're if you're looking for the mahomes
or the josh allen contracts i think
they're their argument and again i'm
just looking at this from the outside
but i'm imagining their argument is no
you're not those guys you are a you're a
great player again you're a pro bowl
caliber player but those guys you're
talking about two of the top you know
three quarterbacks however you want to
look at that in in the league maybe one
and two um so yeah you're not going to
pay you that number because we don't
view you as that type of player but uh i
would imagine he's saying yeah but i'm
next you know that's how these contracts
work doesn't necessarily mean you're
better than the previous guy but you're
the next guy and everything kind of
keeps trending upwards so that's that's
where you have uh a little bit of the
issue would be my guess so um
you know uh uh wouldn't you be concerned
that you know that if he doesn't get
paid that year four
that
there might be
body language moments or shutting it
down moments uh during games where
adversity hits that you'd be concerned
about because he hasn't been paid based
on the the actions over the last three
weeks i mean isn't deep down wouldn't
you be would you be concerned about that
sitting in the cardinals front office
right now i would say i would say if
you're worried about that then you
probably should have bigger issues to be
worried about with him you know going
forward if if his wiring is such that
well then why it worked out then i would
be concerned because if you'd say okay
most guys would say okay
look
pay me now this is what the number is i
know it's an uncomfortable number but
guess what when i go out next year and i
take the next step and we take the next
step that number is only going north um
so i i would prefer to have somebody
that position that would maybe take that
approach and i would imagine i think
that's what lamar jackson will do um and
kind of that in that same boat he's
going to say that's fine you want to you
want to hold off and wait that number is
only going to go up
well i mean in terms of lamar um
eric decosta spoke a couple weeks ago
and i took his his his
his comments to mean
that lamar isn't
negotiating like he's just chilling out
and figuring out he'll get to it when he
gets to it are they talking are you
hearing anything on that i don't know i
have not dan i haven't talked to eric i
have not asked eric that so um maybe
i'll check in with him when we get out
to indianapolis right okay that's uh
it's different ways you approach this
thing right i mean i just keep looking
back at kirk cousins and all the deals
they tried to give him and he said nope
nope nope um and bought bet on himself
and paid off in a big way so i think i'd
rather go that approach than than the
all-caps letter before i let you go
daniel who who give me some names of
some guys that you're you're thinking
can burn it up uh knock the the roof off
of lucas oil coming up this week at the
combine well i mentioned i mentioned
those edge rashers travon walker from uh
from georgia
he's gonna probably run in a high four
fives or low four sixes at 275 pounds um
jermaine johnson from florida state
another edge rusher could run into four
fives 260 plus pounds we've already
talked about how hutchinson is going to
roll i assume thibodeau is going to roll
as well that group's going to be a lot
of fun to watch then wide receivers i
always like giving you a name that's
maybe a little bit off the radar yes but
danny gray from smu i think that second
number is going to be a two
whoo
okay
that's a that that would be something
else that is fast
all right daniel i look forward to
spending a lot more time with you
well i appreciate it man i uh i'm trying
to debate whether or not i'm going to be
going sandwiches or salads this year
richard let's say
you know what salad is a great notion
going in but you please you got to be
kidding me
certainly when you got to eat it with
during a commercial break what are you
going to grab a fork and you know please
you're right come on daniel just don't
be like peyton manning and get caught
eating on the camera yeah
yeah
getting caught eating on camera is a
problem also how's your stationery
oh yeah you want to know did we eat
because go ahead and ask them go ahead
yeah i threw up a poll question when we
all saw eric burkhart's statement this
morning so kyle murray very impressive
stationary yeah we were taking but who
do you think has the best stationary
between you
kyler and mike florio
oh i can tell you this i got married
march 11 2000 and i still have some of
my thank you note stationary left so i'm
not a big apparently i'm not a very good
letter writer yeah they've created more
fonts since then so maybe you want to
get back you have a logo dj no the dj i
think it just has my name embossed at
the top yeah he's not working on it no
and the last thing you want to get is is
a is an envelope from mike florio you
don't want that
i mean that means you're being sued
chapter 14 of playmaker take care
brother i'll see you in indianapolis
take care save flight see you soon
that's daniel jeremiah he's uh check him
in bucky brooks he's about to go do uh
move the sticks right now
right here on the rich eisen show the
podcast hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here